تزداد الجبهات في اوكرانيا سخونه ليست اي
جبهات شبهوا جزيره القرم ومدن البحر
الاسود وبعد ساعات من الهجوم الثانيه على
جسر القرم تتبعه اوكرانيا بهجوم بعشرات
طائرات مسيره على شبه الجزيره القرم هذا
اليوم هجوم تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها احبطته واسقطت عددا كبيرا من
المسيرات وتتحدث عن شنها هجوما انتقاميا
ضربات بصواريخ دقيقه تستهدف مدن البحر
الاسود خصوصا تلك التي توجد فيها موانئ
وتصدير الحبوب اوديسا
مشهد دفع كييف الى التحذير من ان نحو نصف
مليار انسان
سيتضررون من عرقله تصدير الحبوب
اشاره الدفاع الروسيه احباطا محاوله هجوما
اوكرانيه جديده وصفتها بالارهابيه
باستخدام طائرات مسيره على اهداف في شبه
جزيره القرم وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان
الدفاعاتها الجويه اعترضت الماضيه سبعه
عشره مسيره واسقطت احدى عشره مسيره اخرى
باستخدام وسائل الحرب الالكترونيه دون
وقوع خسائر وفق ما قالته الوزاره
وكانت القوات الاوكرانيه قالت امس انها
استهدفت جسر القرمه الاستراتيجي بزورقين
مسيرين
وقالا المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات صاروخيه
عاليه الدقه وصفها بالانتقاميه على منشات
اوكرانيه لتصنيع قوارب قوارب مسيره في
منطقه اوديسا اضاف نادي المسيرات كانت
تستعد لشن هجمات وصفها بالارهابيه على
روسيا
نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه خلال الليل
ضربه شامله انتقاميه باسلحه بحريه عاليه
الدقه على منشاه يتم فيها التحضير لاعمال
ارهابيه ضد روسيا باستخدام قوارب مسيره
وايضا على مواقع لصناعه تلك القوارب في
حوض لبناء السفن بالقرب من مدينه اوديسا
بالاضافه الى ذلك تم تدمير مستودعات
لتخزين الوقود في مقاطاعتين
تبلغ ساعتها نحو 70 الف طن تم منها تزويد
المعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بالوقود
من جانبها قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه لقد خمسه صواريخ اس 360
صاروخا من انواع مختلفه كما قالت وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه ان القوات الروسيه شنت
هجوما صاروخيا وصفته بالكبير على مدن
اوديسا
الاوكرانيه ونشرت صورا قالت انها للهجوم
الصاروخيه التي شنطته القوات الروسيه على
المدن الاوكرانيه الثلاث كما اعلنت تفعيل
منظومه الدفاع الجوي في المنطقه